- Wait, so speaking of
friends coming to a show,
I always tell people to never tell me
if someone comes to a show.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, I hate knowing.
Do you like knowing?
- Well, in a long run like this,
where you're doing the same show.
we've done it 110 times now,
it helps me to see it through new eyes.
- Oh, okay.
- I can get excited
'cause I know so-and-so's out there,
and they're English, so
they'll hate my accent.
- They're judging.
- Or they're really judgy
so they'll hate the whole show.
- Oh man, I don't get nervous on stage,
but when I know that friends
are family or something's,
I'm like, "I don't wanna know."
- I don't know why it
gives me a little kick.
- So one time, speaking of that though,
you actually surprised Sean Hayes, right?
Was in Chicago?
- Yeah, so Sean, if, I
dunno if you got a chance
to see "Goodnight Oscar,"
but he won the Tony for it this year.
- [Kelly] He's so talented.
- He's so incredible.
- And sweet.
- There's us together.
But he did it in Chicago first
and I knew he was doing it,
it was very low key, this
is like year and a half ago.
But I flew in to see him and surprise him
and I told him that night,
"You're going to New York, right?"
He said, "Yeah, hopefully."
And I said, "Yeah, you're
gonna win the Tony."
- Oh my God.
You're like Nostradamus,
you predicted that.
- It was pretty clear.
He was pretty awesome.
- Yeah, he's so talented.